situé au parc de la providence une
maison d'accueil familial a été
inaugurée le vendredi 23 octobre 2020
comme jacqueline aidantes depuis plus de
40 ans beaucoup de représentants
d'associations étaient présents car
cette maison c'est pour eux un peu
d'oxygène
cette maison l'attend depuis quelques
années déjà et c'est une maison pour
accueillir ben les aidants et puis les
aider également et je pense que ça va
nous apporter un peu de soutien
pour qu'on puisse aussi bien souffler se
reposer avoir une écoute
nous attendons beaucoup de cette maison
d'accueil familial de la providence
bon
[Musique]
boum
localement 50 mille personnes sont en
posture d dans un combat de chaque
instant reconnu depuis plusieurs années
par la collectivité qui a engagé la
création de ces structures bienveillante
quand on parle de maison il faut voilà
donner envie aux gens de pouvoir
s'évader
l'idée c'est de pouvoir en fait leur
redonner les on va dire les moyens de
pouvoir effectivement penser à autre
chose tous les jours c'est vrai rester
chez soi toute la journée c'est pas
évident donc nous ce qu'on propose à la
maison d'accueil familial c'est de
pouvoir pouvoir permettre aux aidés
notamment de pouvoir s'évader eux aussi
quand leurs aidants a eu bat eux aussi
vont pouvoir prendre du temps pauvre la
crise sanitaire rend encore plus
difficile le rôle d'aidant à travers
cemaf la solidarité devient alors
essentiel pour le bien-être des
personnes âgées
les porteuses de handicap